Android 5.0 introduced a new way of
writing media playback applications.
Based on media session,
media controller, and
media browser service classes.
One of the nice features of this API
is that apps can be abstracted into two
components.
One part stores and
plays back the media and
the other part provides a user interface
to allow the user to select the item
to play, and a pause, next track, etc.
An interesting side
effect of this design
is that your app can export the media
to other apps running on the device.
So the Android Auto app can query
the available music from your app and
show it using a user interface
appropriate for the car.
Android Wear is also able to do the same
and show user interface appropriate for
the wearable device.
This all works without you having
to right user interfaces for
these other platforms.
If you implement the API correctly,
it all comes for free.
As a final bonus, Android Wear also
includes media browser support.
If you allow Android Wear to
call your own GitRoot method,
it will allow you to browse and
play back music from a wearable device.
You don't need to write any code for
Android Wear, it just works for free.
You can try the Sound player
yourself to see this in action.
So let's talk about how we implement
a media playback app for Android Auto.
This diagram shows three components.
Your app on the right, which is all in
an APK file, the Android Auto Companion
app, this app is responsible for
drawing the user interface and sending
the pixels to the vehicle display, and
this here is the vehicle display itself.
It doesn't do much except draw the
pixels from the Android Auto Companion,
play sound, and caption's voice input.
Inside your app,
you implement a media browser service.
This service maintains a true
structure of all of your media,
such as a collection of music.
This could be either streamed or
stored locally.
Your app also implements
a media session,
which tracks the current state
of what your app is playing.
You implement a MediaSession.Callback,
to get notified of when the user selects
a new song or
when the playback controls are pressed.
The Android Auto App connects to
your media browser service and
queries it to get the tree structure
of your app's music library.
The driver of the car then
gets to select a song
using either the touch screen like
this or using voice search in the car.
Then Android Auto we use the media
session to run your call backs.
So you never have to worry about all the
details of making a user interface that
is safe for driving, because Android
Auto takes care of all that for you.